sean
important
moi
étranger
est
je pense que c'est incroyable
euh
merci
donc
bon après-midi
euh ministre des affaires étrangères lavrov et j'ai eu
fini notre réunion il y a un moment
et je veux d'abord commencer par remercier la
suisse d'avoir accueilli
euh les discussions de la semaine dernière
la crise en ukraine
et la sécurité européenne plus large
notre objectif était de déterminer si la
russie est prête
à prendre une voie diplomatique
oh
[Musique]
étranger
étranger de manière
agressive sans euh utiliser ouvertement
des messages militaires
nous sommes unis dans nos engagements
[Musique]
est
plusieurs idées
discutées euh la euh la  voie à suivre
permettez-moi de dire aussi
qu'il a entendu parler de nous
euh
et pour moi que euh ce qui est pour nous une
règle invitable
euh rien sur l'ukraine sans l'ukraine
rien sur l'otan sans l'otan rien
sur la personne que
je crois que
nous pouvons faire avancer
peut conduire à la paix
[Musique]
étrangère discussions aujourd'hui le ministre des affaires étrangères
lavrov et moi avons convenu que c'était
important
je lui ai dit qu'à la suite des
consultations
qui ont eu lieu  Nous aurons dans les prochains jours avec
euh des alliés et un partenariat
euh
serait la meilleure façon euh d'avancer
mais
encore une fois euh
je devrais également mentionner un
exemple de la façon dont les États étrangers et la
Russie peuvent travailler
avec l'Iran sur un retour mutuel à la
conformité  avec le jcpoa euh ont
atteint un moment décisif
euh
merci monsieur le secrétaire
monsieur
étranger
um
sont des propositions non partantes pour limiter l'
expansion de l'otan
étranger
pensez-vous qu'il y a la possibilité
euh
des actions de stabilisation
donc
comme je l'ai dit ce n'est pas sur la base  d'
émotion ce n'est pas la base de fait la
russie a
envahi l'ukraine en 2014
s'emparant de la crimée
euh les
responsables russes disent qu'ils n'ont pas l'
intention de débattre que
nous avons
dans la diplomatie et le dialogue c'est ce que
nous avons fait aujourd'hui
et ce que nous avons prévu
euh
non seulement
pour répondre aux préoccupations  que la russie
a soulevé
au cours des conversations que
nous avons eues aujourd'hui sur
les positions des uns et des autres
et après avoir consulté
euh très intensément avec euh le
président biden
voulait que j'aie cette opportunité de
digérer ce que nous avons entendu la semaine dernière
voir où nous en sommes
euh
dans la mesure où la
russie est engagée euh
pour l'instant
dans la diplomatie mais en même temps
continue de
prendre l'escalade
est
euh une plus grande transparence
activités
euh
diverses euh mesures de réduction des risques d'
autres façons de renforcer la confiance que euh
sur les principes fondamentaux
et que nous nous engageons à défendre
la porte ouverte de l'otan
[Musique]
ses politiques de
longues conversations sur le passé
nous continuerons
euh
oh je suis désolé je
dois  aborder cela euh ainsi de suite ou sur euh je
dois dire que euh la russie
partage notre sens de l'urgence de
revenir à une conformité mutuelle
dans
les semaines à venir
et euh
refuse d'
assumer les obligations qui
sont nécessaires
euh que euh nous suivrons une voie différente
euh
euh après quatre assez concluants
[Musique]
eh
bien je suis sûr que cela a un sens intuitif
pour de nombreux américains
euh d'
abord sur la euh
la deuxième partie de la
euh les questions
ont euh
ma  de clair euh et fait
un certain nombre de choses euh pour soutenir et euh
pour la défense de l'ukraine non non non
non cela continuera
nous avons
continué à
fournir à l'ukraine
une aide militaire importante en matière de défense
depuis euh depuis 2014.
le renforcement de l'otan
ukraine est très précieux
euh étend aux alliés de l'otan
quelque chose
une détermination à faire tout ce que nous pouvons
euh
ce que nous avons convenu aujourd'hui est que euh
[Applaudissements]
soulevé
sur la base de la conversation d'aujourd'hui sur la base de
cela ainsi que du document que nous avons reçu
merci euh
je me demandais si  euh alors
que vous continuez à revenir pour plus de
dialogue plus de discussions avec les russes
ils continuent d'agir ils ont continué
pourquoi pas
nous n'attendons pas
euh pour agir euh pour contrer la russie
comme je l'ai dit il y a un instant nous avons engagé
plus d'aide à la sécurité en ukraine  dans
le passé
qu'à tout autre moment
dans le monde
qui opèrent en Ukraine et qui
cherchent à déstabiliser le pays
et encore une fois, comme je l'ai dit, nous avons clairement fait savoir
à la
Russie qu'ils  feraient face
euh
euh nous sommes embarqués sur une voie de défense
et de dissuasion ces choses ne sont pas
mutuellement incompatibles en fait elles se
renforcent
en termes de
euh et affinent
des conséquences massives
pour l'
interprétation russe serait que euh
parfois
[Musique]
je dois dire aujourd'hui
nous avons certainement entendu des choses qui euh
euh
c'est important de tester si nous pouvons euh
je voulais parler des mesures
euh
cette dernière question est probablement mieux
adressée au
président à nouveau comme je le disais plus tôt
je pense que euh comme nous avons
regardé quoi  euh la russie a mis en
avant comme nous l'avons
écouté euh
est
oh
[musique]
améliorer la sécurité pour tout le monde pour pour nous
pour vos
exercices militaires européens euh contrôle des armements la
russie veut en fait
ce qui me frappe et j'ai partagé ça
avec euh avec la sécurité étrangère
pratiquement tout
euh
les notes de faveur de la russie euh en
ukraine
étaient de 70
maintenant ils sont 25 ou 30 pour cent
avant 2014
avant qu'ils ne s'emparent de la crimée et
euh sont allés euh dans le  don pass
support in ukraine
25 ou
renforcement euh nos forces
en europe depuis la fin de la guerre froide
eh bien euh ce qui s'est passé après 2014 est l'otan
ressenti l'obligation à cause de l'agression russe
et maintenant
si la russie renouvelle son agression contre l'
ukraine
euh le euh le résultat  sera simplement de
renforcer
très
j'espère que c'est quelque chose sur lequel euh
euh
mr lavrov réfléchit et que le président
poutine pourrait refléter
votre pitié